the legacy news outlets from cnn to fox
and all the squishy republicans from
mitt romney to jeb
have named joe biden the president-elect
that is the bad news the good news is
that none of those people and none of
those organizations
gets to decide presidential elections
despite what the media want you to
believe
the election is far from over
joe biden is not the president-elect
we will get into why and how we got here
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from last week comes from t
welsh who said if we were democrats half
the country would be burned down by
today
that is true you know i'm living in los
angeles still for another couple of days
and all the shops and all the nice areas
are boarded up they're boarded
up and yet there have been no riots why
were there no riots because the media
have preemptively
declared joe biden the winner if they
had named trump the winner
i think those boards would be doing a
lot of work right now and i think
there'd be shattered glass all around
the streets
but conservatives are not the ones
riding conservatives are remaining
cool as a cucumber we're remaining cool
as a cucumber
because the process isn't over no matter
what cnn says and no matter what fox
news says for that matter
it is not over yet
we will have to wait and see and we'll
have to figure out where we go
from here these are important things to
talk about and
when you talk by the way you should try
to save a lot of money what if there
were a company that gives you an amazing
deal on talking on your cell phone every
single day
that would be pure talk usa a
veteran-run wireless company
think of i don't know think of att or
verizon or t-mobile
but much much better if you're using
verizon att or t-mobile
you are paying too much and you could be
getting the exact same coverage
for a lot less money i know you think
that what i'm saying is
you could get similar coverage for a lot
less money i'm not saying that
you could get the exact same coverage
same tower same network
for example if you want to get unlimited
talk
text and two gigs of data you can get
that for just 20 bucks a month
not 20 bucks a month plus 80 bucks of
fees
not not 20 bucks plus 100 in charges no
20 bucks a month if you go over on your
data usage guess what
they don't charge you for it how wild is
that switching to pure talk is the
easiest decision you will make today
you can keep your phone and your number
or you know if you want to upgrade a
little bit
you get great deals on the latest
iphones and android
head on over grab your mobile phone dial
pound 250 and say
michael knowles when you do you will
save 50 off your first month
now pound 2 5 0 say keyword michael
knowles pure talk is simply smarter
wireless you know
i hate to say i told you so you know how
much i hate to say that
i actually do hate to say that in this
case because
i predicted this election outcome over a
month ago
i actually had forgotten that i
described it this way but i had been
doing an interview with matt fradd i
believe it was on october 8th
and i try never to make predictions i
don't think it is the role
of political commentators to make
predictions i think
their role is to talk about what's
happening now what it means but he asked
me at the end of the this long interview
he said you have any predictions and i
said yeah here's what i think
i think 60 chance if it's a fair vote
that trump wins
so put a little bit of money on him but
it's not going to be a fair vote because
there are going to be
lots of shenanigans going on
particularly in those swing states that
are going to describe the election
the universal mail-in ballots mean that
we're already in
a constitutional crisis because those
are super right for fraud
uh you know bush v gore was just one
state this time we're probably going to
have bush v
gore in three states if not five states
then the election will be decided by the
courts and we're not going to find out
anywhere close to election day
that was the prediction and i only even
remembered it because someone
after the election found that interview
and started tweeting it around and
saying oh my gosh look at this
so then we cut it out you can go it's
broken out you can see it on our youtube
channel
i i don't say any of this because i
think i'm nostradamus or because i had a
crystal ball
i'm saying this because if you were
paying attention
to the legal machinations that were
going on before the election
the way that the courts were ruling on
how mail-in votes would be counted
on deadlines if you know the history of
the political machine in philadelphia in
particular
if you pay it in detroit as well if you
knew those things and you
knew you you didn't believe the media
narrative on mail-in ballots
which is they were saying that mail-in
ballots were perfectly normal perfectly
fine happened all the time
no evidence of fraud if you realized
that the universal unsolicited mailings
were completely unprecedented you knew
a month ago or even two months ago we
were already
in a constitutional crisis and that is
where we are right now because
there is evidence of illegal activity at
these polling places
because of this this will be litigated
joe biden
despite what you're reading in the press
right now is
not the president-elect i'm not saying
that because i'm saying there's no way
joe biden could ultimately
ascend to the presidency or be named
president there is
a distinct chance that he could do that
i'm saying that because just as a purely
technical matter
the states have not certified him the
winner right now
there are multiple key states that are
being hotly contested
there will be recounts almost certainly
in these states this will be
battled out in court there is evidence
that the law was broken
so i'm not saying this is wishful
thinking or anything like that just as a
purely technical matter
joe biden is not the president-elect the
presidential election
has not been decided the associated
press and the washington post and cnn
and all these guys
want to call it that's what they did on
saturday i woke up
uh in here in l.a and first thing i see
in the morning is that cnn was the first
to call it
followed by nbc abc the associated press
a couple minutes later
fox news as well that's a that's
unfortunate
uh number of outlets called it no reason
to call it yet
the election is decided first by the
states
which will certify winners and then the
electoral college will vote on december
14th
and before then we're going to have
litigation and recounts hopefully
and who knows maybe it'll go even past
that deadline
in philadelphia and i'll just use this
one example when people tell you there's
no evidence of fraud
here's the evidence in phil in
all elections there are there are poll
watchers
this is why it's better to have just one
election day
be and a minimal use of mail-in ballots
because
it's much easier to cheat on mail-ins
and it's easier to cheat when the time
frame is longer campaigns send what are
called poll watchers
to polling places and as the votes are
being counted you've got the democrat
poll watcher and the republican poll
watcher
checking to make sure that no one's
pulling any tricks the people who poll
tricks tend to be democrats
almost exclusively because the tricks
are pulled in these cities that are run
by democrats
which are run by the machine so you got
the poll watchers looking in
philadelphia
republicans were not allowed to send
their poll watchers
to look at the count now this was
highly illegal the republicans went to
the courts
got a court order the judge was saying
that the poll workers were violating the
law by not allowing the republican poll
watchers so the republican poll watchers
go back with their court order guess
what
they still don't get in why not what was
going on in philadelphia
very difficult for me to believe that
there was not other illegal activity
going on beyond
the poll watchers not being permitted in
that's just one
city in one crucial state there is a lot
of other evidence of shenanigans there
have been
reports of dead people voting this
republicans do this
all the time we've got confirmed reports
of something like 15 dead people voting
could be
significantly more now obviously 15
votes is not going to sway an election
but we've also got reports of glitches
quote unquote
in the voting software that switched say
three or four thousand votes from
trump to biden and then that was caught
in michigan
how much was not caught this kind of
poll software was used
in multiple counties something like 47
counties
was it the software's fault was it human
error if it was error
why do all of the errors always seem to
work
in joe biden's favor against donald
trump isn't that a bit of a coincidence
there are some excellent uh analyses
going on right now
you can catch some of it on twitter
before it gets booted off or in other
platforms on the internet where people
are doing statistical analyses of these
hundred thousand vote dumps somehow all
for joe biden the
anomaly of so many ballots with only joe
biden selected no down ticket races
now uh is is there proof that this is
going on
i guess we're gonna have to find out
little
little pieces here and there but is
there proof that it's systemic we're
gonna have to find out
is there proof that it's enough to swing
a presidential election we don't know
that's why we're gonna have to find out
that's why this has to go to court why
this legal process
has to take over as of right now though
here's the one thing i know
it would be absolutely insane for
president trump to concede
before the legal process plays out
it would be insane there's a lot of
pressure right now from all those
democrats who are urging unity and
healing
you know the people who two two weeks
ago were burning
the country down threatening us
physically
threatening to destroy our political
system if
if we didn't give them the election well
right now those people are pressuring
trump to concede it would be an
absolute uh abnegation of duty if he
conceded right now there is no reason to
do it
the the process will have to play out in
the courts joe biden by the way
was going to do this same thing if
somehow the machines worked differently
and joe biden were the one who were down
a little bit right now you know that he
would be
pushing this in courts he hired 600
lawyers to litigate this
a few months ago hillary clinton said
that joe biden should concede under no
circumstances
including a clear trump victory so no i
don't think donald trump
should concede do you remember the 2000
presidential election
do you remember bush vigor al gore who
had no case by the way his case was so
weak
it was only in one state and there was
no evidence of fraud
al gore dragged that process out for 38
days
what are we in right now day five or
something like that
day six no way should president trump
let this go
in fewer than 38 days the
liberals right now and the concerned
troll
foe conservatives are in this push for
trump to concede
in in the name of healing and patriotism
and dignity
give me a break there's nothing
dignified in rolling over
when we have evidence of at least
certain
illegal actions that harmed the
integrity of our election
at least in philadelphia a crucial state
no way but of course the squishes
want to come out and concede the
election on trump's behalf so
jeb jeb jeb
yeb i think is how you say it two
exclamation points
he tweeted out quote congratulations to
president-elect biden
i have prayed for our president most of
my adult life
i will be praying for you and your
success now is the time to heal deep
wounds
many are counting on you to lead the way
i think it's perfectly right
to pray for the president the current
president donald trump
and for his opponent joe biden it's good
to pray for those who persecute you it's
good to pray
for the crooked election workers in
philadelphia even
doesn't mean we need to roll over and
acquiesce to their nefarious actions or
pretend
that joe biden is the president-elect
when he's not
something tells me jeb bush did not vote
for donald trump just a hunch
something tells me he may have very
likely voted for joe biden
so this is not this is now being
portrayed in the media as this wonderful
graciousness from that republican that
conservative jeb bush
how wonderful we should all follow his
example i don't think so i think jeb
bush is very likely
happy that that joe biden may have
beaten donald trump i guess we just
don't know we're going to find out later
and fair enough jeb jeb bush took it
pretty hard from donald trump
probably without jeb there's no
president trump because
jeb was the foil for president trump so
i get it the guy has a personal beef
with him okay
doesn't mean the rest of us should roll
over mitt romney same goes for him
mitt romney tweets out ann and i are
extend our congratulations
to president-elect joe biden and vice
president-elect kamala harris
we know both of them as people of
goodwill and admirable character
we pray that god may bless them in the
days and years ahead yeah i pray that
god may bless them too i
as we as we all do i pray for all these
miserable sinners that we see here on
earth
ourselves included however
we don't congratulate these people as
the president and vice president-elect
because
they are not yet that thing i love this
idea we know both of them as people of
goodwill and admirable character
joe biden is the most notorious liar in
the united states
and he has been since 1988 when he had
to drop out of the election for
lying joe biden said that donald trump
is a racist he started his campaign on a
lie the lie that
trump called nazis fine people at
charlottesville never happened put that
one away with the tooth fairy and the
easter bunny it simply isn't true
joe biden lied and and slandered a man
who was involved in that tragic car
accident that involved joe biden's wife
but he lied about it
the man it haunted him his whole life
there was no evidence that the man had
done anything wrong was just a terrible
accident
and yet after the man died joe biden
said he was a drunk driver
vicious vicious pathological lies
i i don't think joe biden's a
particularly good guy i think joe biden
sues nuns
and he's going to sue nuns again he's
promised to do it because they won't pay
for abortion drugs i think joe
joe biden supports abortion on demand
taxpayer-funded i don't think he's a
good guy at all
and frankly i don't think mitt romney is
a very good guy we have this line on the
right where we say
oh mitt romney poor mitt
he was so maligned in 2012
in particular by joe biden who said that
mitt romney wants to put black people in
chains
neither here nor there oh poor mitt he
was such a good man
what a good man mitt was and he was so
his character was besmirched by the
democrats
how is he a good man he's another
he's another notorious liar in politics
he flip-flopped on every single issue
his whole life he always went for
expediency when he was running for
senate against
teddy teddy kennedy he said that he was
not a republican during the time of
reagan bush he completely disavowed
ronald reagan
and pretended to be an independent he
described himself as very pro-choice
and defended abortion he though then he
invented obamacare remember that when he
invented obamacare
and then he attacked an actual
conservative who ran for president
donald trump
even after groveling for his endorsement
in 2012 i don't think mitt romney is a
particularly good guy either i think
i've had enough
of this idea that donald trump is this
awful terrible man with so many unique
character flaws
not like those good people you know mitt
romney give me a break
i'm not saying donald trump is pure as
the newly driven snow
but frankly i think he's much more
honest and has greater political
humility
than any of these clowns and so no i
don't think we need to follow their
wonderful gracious example
something tells me mitt romney didn't
want
didn't want donald trump to win in the
first place there's one nice thing i can
say about mitt romney he's got a good
head of hair and by the way guys if you
want to keep a nice head of hair
you got to use keeps so much of our
identity is wrapped up in our hair you
know as as fellas
so we think about how it feels after
getting a fresh cut
we think about the way it's styled
before going out we think about even if
we're not
total adonises or any or you know
olympians
if you got a nice head of hair sometimes
you can do well in the lady department
that is why when we get into our 20s and
30s start noticing those first signs of
hair loss
feels like panic time but it doesn't
have to be the important thing with
keeps is you start using it right away
it will help you keep
your hair today and tomorrow you can get
treated from home
you just have to go to the doctor's
office for a hair loss prescription now
you don't need to do that
prevention is the key keeps treatments
typically take
four to six months to see results so
it's important you got to act fast
the sooner you start using keeps the
more hair that you will save
find out why keeps has more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors
and more than 100 000 men trust keeps
for their hair loss prevention
medication best of all starts at just 10
bucks per month if you are ready to take
action
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
knowles nwles
to receive your first month of treatment
for free that is k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash knowles
the romney problem really drives me nuts
i have to tell you that was another one
i don't want to say i told you so
don't want to say i was nostradamus here
however
i had mitt romney's number from the very
beginning back in 2012 i worked for two
of mitt romney's primary opponents
because i knew mitt was going to be a
complete disaster as the republican
nominee
and probably not a very good president
if he got elected and
i that was absolutely correct
republicans like mitt romney that right
liberal republicans like mitt romney
and all of these other clowns who are
eagerly
rolling over today to the left typify a
phenomenon i've mentioned on the show a
couple times before
i call it court jester conservatism
the court jester conservatives offer
limp
opposition to the dominant liberal
regime and the dominant liberal regime
that we see
that totally controls big tech the
mainstream media the legacy media
the hollywood media that controls
administrative government that controls
higher education controls lower
education right it is
it is the dominant regime even when
republicans sometimes win elections
doesn't matter the liberal regime still
reigns
the liberal regime loves the court
jester conservatives loves that they
offer limp opposition
because that limp opposition actually
legitimizes
the liberal regime you know even saddam
hussein
when he would when he would be
re-elected by overwhelming margins
he'd always leave about three percent to
the opposition
so that he could say see there's
opposition here i'm not just a dictator
well that's how the liberal regime works
with court jester conservatives
they they allow this kind of little fake
fight and then they win
then sometimes when the corchester
conservatives have been completely
gelded
completely castrated the liberal regime
will offer them praise and plaudits they
will say
we have a strange new respect for mitt
romney we have a strange new respect for
george w bush right people that they
called
monsters nazis hitler at the time that
they threatened them in any way
then they offered the strange new
respect and the corchester conservatives
are really happy to get that so thank
you so much
so wonderful to be respected by you
joe biden may ascend to the presidency
he may be named president
or the courts may find and disqualify
enough fraudulent votes
that joe biden does not become president
that president trump is reelected
we don't know we don't know how it's
going to play out tough court battle
that president trump faces
i hope he's got good evidence very
difficult to prove voter fraud anyway
that's that's why it's fraud that's why
because it's very tricky
and because you're on a timetable you
know very often you can get away with it
we don't know what's going to happen but
here is one thing i do know
and it is the key and you should look
around you right now
the people who are clamoring at present
for president trump to concede
the people who are so eager to call joe
biden president-elect
and go along with the liberal narrative
of national healing which they're not
interested in by the way
we'll get to that in a second those
people
those court jester conservatives never
wanted trump to win in the first place
never look around because i think a lot
of us were
stunned on election night that that
ostensibly conservative outlets
were some of the first people out the
gate to throw the election for joe biden
or at least to try to
maybe they weren't all that conservative
in the first place maybe
it's pretend maybe it's a show and
we should look around right now because
this is
the fight there are lots of issues at
stake right now
there are lots of issues healthcare lots
of issues like
life lots of issues like a school choice
by the way speaking of school choice
homeschool magnet supports homeschooling
families
by providing students with instruction
from world-class credentialed teachers
in a remote classroom with their peers
huge fan of
homeschool magnet parents choose the
best teachers for each student
based on values and teaching approach to
ensure that every child is receiving
exactly the education that they deserve
this puts you as the parent in full
control
of your child's education without the
daily responsibilities
of lesson planning pre-learning teaching
tutoring and grading
it's a lot i mean that would be so much
and i know that people right now
with the lockdowns have a lot of
students at home even if they weren't
doing homeschooling before
you got to check out homeschool magnet
each student will receive instruction in
the four core subject areas
of gender studies underwater basket
weaving
lesbian dance theory no no i'm joking
that's not that's not what you're going
to receive
you're going to receive instruction in
the four actual core subject areas
of math english language arts science
and social studies
this approach is similar to most remote
college learning formats
will help prepare students for secondary
school with homeschool magnet
you get the freedom and control of
homeschooling without the burden
to learn more about homeschool magnet
student experience go to
homeschoolmagnet.com
join the growing wait list for
interested teachers who want more
freedom in their teaching career
homeschool magnet may be perfect for you
we are recruiting teachers
right now for homeschool magnets so head
on over homeschoolmagnet.com
michael to learn more and apply
people think look we put up a good fight
and that's it and now we just have to
move on
look they've got they called it they
called it cnn said so
and look they got it's hard to prove
fraud and you know it's gonna be long in
court
and let's just move on right this this
it's over
no no this
is the moment this is it
they'll they'll hear them say they'll
say look we were gonna win the economy
was great everyone was doing great
until just whoopsie daisy there was
covid and those lockdowns
who could have predicted the lockdowns
you know who could have predicted the
lockdowns the democratic
politicians who put them in place to
steal the election
that's who look we were gonna win until
we had because of the then the lockdowns
we had to have universal mail in ballots
and maybe that didn't help us but look
it was just a big accident it wasn't an
accident it was on purpose
the reason that they instituted the
universal mail in ballots was to make it
easier to get electoral benefits for
themselves whether they were legitimate
or not
that was the point well look we put up a
good fight but now that no
yeah now is the moment now is the moment
guys do not let them get away with this
without a fight
joe biden may still win one way or
another he may still win
don't give up do not give up the fight
yet there is no reason to they are
trying to demoralize you
before the election they tried to
demoralize you with fake polls
that were completely wrong and those
pollsters should have no credibility in
the future
they used those polls to suppress
republican voting
and then guess what happened republican
voting would blew them way out of the
water frankly even if biden wins
the polling was completely wrong now
they're trying to discourage you
by telling you for national unity we all
have to concede and give up the account
i don't think so i don't think so buddy
president trump thankfully
is not yet doing that either he gave an
excellent a press conference from the
white house
and the heads on msnbc almost completely
exploded
if you count the legal votes i easily
win
if you count the illegal votes they can
try to
steal the election from us if you count
the votes that came in late
we're looking at them very strongly but
a lot of votes came in late
i've already decisively won many
critical states including massive
victories in florida
iowa indiana ohio okay here we are
again in the unusual position of not
only interrupting the president of the
united states but
correcting the president of the united
states
on the unusual position brian of
interrupting
and correcting the president that's what
you've been doing for four years
right now if you go onto twitter almost
every single trump tweet has some
censorship on it some warning sim line
says this isn't true this is disputed
mail-in voting is safe click here to
learn how safe and great mail-in voting
is
it's creepy stuff it's orwellian stuff
and they've been doing it from the
beginning the reason
that they can't interrupt him totally
successfully is because he's such a
a rock star he's such a celebrity that
all the cameras have to be on him
trump did not tell a single lie right
there not one single lie
he won states he has as much if not a
greater claim to having won states
that are in dispute as joe biden has
that guy does not appear to be going
down without a fight damn right he
shouldn't
he will say please just quit with
dignity with dignity there's nothing
dignified about rolling over for you
people like brian williams
no way and by the way even even if the
courts
do throw the election to joe biden which
there
are other there's another world in which
by the way i don't want us
i don't want to uh seem too enthusiastic
about this
because i think it's it's unlikely to
happen but hope springs eternal in the
human breast
there is a world in which if if the
states cannot figure out the election by
the deadline by december 14th
there is a world in which the vote goes
to the house of representatives
and the house of representatives you'll
know is run by the democrats right now
but that's actually not how the voting
for president the house of
representatives would go it would go by
state delegation and their
republicans actually do have a majority
so there is a word this is a very very
unlikely scenario so i hesitate even to
bring it up
but even that is still a possibility
that you could have the election decided
by the house of representatives
again probably not going to happen but
it's one of these
examples where i say why on earth
would we throw the election after
five or six days when there's real
evidence of problems here
when al gore wouldn't concede it for 38.
when when the democrats say you need to
be dignified it's unprecedented you
can't do this you can't do that
they themselves did this 20 years ago
and and actually the democratic nominee
in 2016 still hasn't given up her claim
to the presidency she still says
that election was illegitimate again no
evidence that it was whatsoever here we
at least have evidence that evidence
needs to be examined and most
importantly
most importantly we need to lap up the
remaining leftist tears if biden is
going to ascend
i hope he doesn't but if he if he is to
ascend if the system is just so stacked
against trump
that that he can't overcome it we at
least need to lap up the remaining
leftist tears and that comes to us
by way of stephen colbert who is so
heartbroken that donald trump won't just
roll over
so we all knew he would do this
all right there they go here come the
waterworks
oh wow his head's down hand on his hip
i can't can't believe it so awful
what i didn't know is that it would hurt
so much
i didn't expect this to break my heart
for him to cast a dark shadow on our
most sacred right
from the briefing room in the white
house our house not his
that is devastating this
this is heartbreaking for the same
reason that
i didn't want him to get coveted
certainly why i wanted him to survive
because he is the president of the
united
states that office means something and
that office should have some shred
of decency it's so heartbreaking that
trump would cast a shadow over our most
sacred right and institution
voting you know cast a shadow like we
have done relentlessly
for four years and blamed russia and the
macedonians
and this and that and this and that
and not granted even for a second that
trump legitimately won in 2016.
so heartbreaking that trump would also
raise
legitimate questions about the election
heart
so hard cry me a river stephen cry me a
river of crocodile tears
because i am not going to believe for
even one second
that this is a genuine uh sadness
the sadness is that you thought that you
all could kick out the orange man
without us raising even one question to
the
very distinct possibility of illegal
activity
well actually we have proof of the
illegal activity at least in philly
you thought we would roll over and we're
not going to do it sorry buster
we're not going to do that one little
bit
all this unity talk you know we're
getting it from the crocodile tears
people over there on the left
say what you will about alexandria
ocasio-cortez
at least she's being honest about her
view and her view is essentially that
they've got to send us all to the gulags
which
we will get to in a second we'll get to
the ways to avoid our trip to the gulag
first though you know joe biden is the
projected winner of the 2020 election
from the establishment media
okay and if if joe biden does become
president it's pretty clear
that that establishment media will have
played a role in that event
if conservatives care about a truly free
press
they must abandon that legacy media
cartel
all of them every single one there's no
exception and they must support
alternatives now more than ever this new
white house if we are to have it
will need a check okay hopefully we
don't have a new white house hopefully
we keep
the old white house and hopefully the
courts will figure that out
but if the media really did throw this
thing to biden then they're going to
need a check and that's why you got to
head on over to daily wire okay we've
got big plans coming up regardless of
how the politics turn out for the next
four years
we've got big plans for the next four
years candace owens will be joining the
daily wire we'll be launching a brand
new show with us early next year in
nashville
as well as uh writing content for us
over at dailywire.com we'll also be
launching an entertainment channel
a new investigative journalism team and
building partnerships with like-minded
content creators like prageru
whose entire show library will be
available to dailywire.com members
by the end of the year which is great
you know i have a show at prageru so
you're gonna get you're gonna get a lot
of extra content
let's show the socialists what it really
means to redistribute wealth
replace your subscription to legacy
outlets and to show your support for the
daily wire today
keep the leftist tears coming for now
today tomorrow for four years and into
the future
head on over to dailywire.com we'll be
right back with a lot more
the left is not interested in unity or
healing they're lying and pretending
that they are so that we roll over and
prematurely concede a presidential
election but in their moments of honesty
they're telling us what they really want
to do and that is punish
conservatives aoc tweets out quote is
anyone
archiving these trump sycophants for
when they try to downplay or deny their
complicity
in the future i foresee decent
probability of many deleted tweets
writings photos in the future their
complicity
is anyone archiving those who have
supported trump why
why does she want to archive people's
support for trump
is it so she can give us awards in the
future
so she can give us a pat on the back i
don't think so she's going to give us
something in the back probably not a pat
they want to punish people who have
supported trump
you you did not see this from the trump
administration when the trump
administration entered
you did not see them trying to punish
obama-era people
they the one the one group we do want to
punish are the deep staters who spied on
the trump campaign and who tried to
overturn
the the duly elected president from 2016
to the present
which i think has a lot to do with this
particular election
but you didn't see us saying we're going
to punish obama supporters for giving us
obamacare
never happened but the left is
vindictive trump was not supposed to win
in 2016.
it wasn't supposed to happen it was a
glitch in the system the ruling dominant
liberal regime and they are out for
blood for anyone who allowed that glitch
to happen they sure weren't going to let
it happen again in 2020
and they're fighting tooth and nail to
prevent that
when we joke about we would say oh
they're going to send us the gulags
sometimes i wonder i say are we just
being you know
overly emotional here do they they don't
really want to send us to the gulags
they do
they do aoc has told us they do
not just aoc number of blue checks we're
talking about the trump accountability
project
if you go if you google the trump
accountability project click on it
you'll see the headline
remember what they did we must never
forget those who furthered the trump
agenda
we should welcome in our fellow
americans with whom we differ
politically
but there we go you know the butts
negate sentences here
but those who took a paycheck from the
trump administration
should not profit from their efforts to
tear our democracy apart
tear our democracy apart by working with
the duly elected president
because democracy is only democracy when
the democrats win
even if the democrats have to cheat and
steal and undermine democracy to win
that's still democracy it's an amazing
thing but when the people vote against
them
that's not democracy that's tearing our
democracy apart the trump accountability
project goes on
the world should never forget those who
when faced with a decision
chose to put their money their time and
their reputations behind separating
children from their families
the obama era policy encouraging racism
and anti-semitism
racism and anti-semite who i see that on
the left i don't see a lot of that on
the right
and negligently causing the unnecessary
loss of life
and economic devastation from our
country's failed response to the
covet-19 pandemic
trump handled kovitt much better than
the democratic governors
worst handling in the country by a by a
political leader was
andrew cuomo democrat who needlessly
killed thousands of people
because directly because of his policies
trump actually did a very good job so
that's all
bs and then here's the kicker we should
not allow the following groups of people
to profit from their experience those
who elected him
trump those who staffed his government
those who funded him
so those who elected him those who
worked for him and those who funded him
so everybody
everyone who supported trump they're
going to punish and try to keep
from having a normal life and try to
keep from working
and try to ostracize from society i love
how it opens
say we should welcome in our fellow
americans with whom we differ
politically
just not those who supported trump i
i get this all the time from my i think
well-intentioned
liberal friends and relatives they'll
say michael look
michael you're you're you're a smart guy
you're a reasonable guy
okay i get it you're a conservative
that's okay you're allowed to be a
conservative mike i would never suggest
not me i'm an open-minded liberal i
would never suggest
that you cannot be a conservative or a
republican no you can
you just can't win elections that's what
they say
look you can support you can support any
republican you want as long as
he's no longer politically active or as
long as he's a complete loser
you just can't support trump you can't
why not what's wrong with you because
trump supports conservative policies
right that's why i like him yeah no you
can't that's
you can't support him you could support
look i didn't agree with george bush
but you can support george bush say well
it's funny because at the time
when conservatives did support george
bush you said we were all nazis and
racists and
it was unacceptable and back then what
you said was
you can support any republican you want
as long as it's not george bush
you can support bob dole you can support
george h.w bush but you're just you
can't support
george bush because he was the current
president now it's trump it's the same
thing
and in four or eight years hopefully in
like 16 or 20 years
you're gonna after trump is out of
office maybe by then you'll you'll hear
people say look
you can be a republican you just can't
sit but you can support guys like donald
trump or george bush but you can't
support
whoever the current republican is right
what they're saying and i don't even
think they mean to do it is
listen you can be a court jester in the
kingdom of liberalism
listen you can play your little role and
do a little soft shoe for us and
entertain us and legitimize our regime
but you can't actually
threaten our regime you can't actually
do anything that contradicts what we
want
that's outrageous people have sent me
these notes i've said michael get off
the
get off the ship you've got to come on
this is awful
get get away from trump now you had your
fun
get away now you can't do it and you
know what i say
i don't really care about about the
preserving the liberal dominant regime
i'm not interested in doing that i know
that there are many
people who call themselves conservatives
and who are republicans
who explicitly want to do that that is
their stated goal
they're happy that biden may have won
we'll find out
but that's not me i'm not that kind of a
conservative i'm not interested in being
a court jester
in the kingdom of liberalism i'm
interested in winning and we still might
win and we should still hold out to win
and try to win this thing in court
there are some benefits though to the
left thinking that joe biden is the
president-elect
first benefit kovit is cured they cured
it
they cured it we just we just got
breaking news right before the show
pfizer has come out and said there's a
study 90
effective vaccine just came out wow what
they didn't they didn't even wait a week
they couldn't even wait one full week
after the election
to announce that covet is cured they got
the news that joe biden maybe won they
think he won and so
kovit is cured even then even before we
got the news this morning on the vaccine
didn't matter that we didn't have a
vaccine
because the legacy media were saying you
don't need to worry about covet anymore
here's a headline from the hill
indoor concerts may be made safe from
coronavirus spread new
study finds oh indoor concerts are okay
now huh
they're they're all right you don't what
about social distancing is that
indoor concerts you don't have social
distancing no it's okay
notice by the way they don't say that
church services are okay now
that they say no those those are going
to be prohibited for quite some time
but you know riots looting and now i
guess indoor concerts that's okay
kovid is cured as as a lot of people
predicted it would be
now i don't think by the way i don't
take the simple view that they're just
going to completely say it's all fine
the day after the election i think they
got a lot of power i think
they're not going to want to give up
that power there if joe biden does win
they're going to want the economy to
recover a bit so that they can take
credit for that
so but what i suspect they'll do is
they'll do a really hard
lockdown of some sort you know they'll
make us all wear the masks or they'll
make us all get the vaccine or they'll
do they'll take
some action that will that they can
point to and say we made you do that
and then regardless of what happens
they're gonna they're gonna say that
covet is cured
and they're gonna take credit for doing
it even well by the way europe is
locking down again
i don't know if anyone's paying it no
one's paying attention to europe
europe's not even paying attention to
europe they're paying attention to the
u.s election
but countries in europe are locking down
again because of a second wave
of coronavirus cases so just looking
around
now would not be the time if if you were
gonna institute these lockdown measures
in the first place
now would not be the time to let them go
but
it is the time if they think joe biden
has won and joe biden for his part
he wants to heal not just in the case of
coronavirus he wants
wants to heal the nation he says quote
it's time to put away the harsh rhetoric
to lower the temperature
to see each other again to listen to
each other again
that's really nice joe joe biden the a
man who disgracefully
called the president of the united
states a racist told him to shut up
on a debate stage a disgusting man joe
biden
a really despicable fellow
you know a typical politician in many
ways i'm not even saying he's
particularly
despicable but he's typically despicable
joe biden says we got to put away the
harsh rhetoric
we got to lower the temperature see each
other again listen to each other again
you know in other words
accept that i won before the states have
certified the election
you know what i think it's time to do i
think it's time to go to court
i think it's time to sue i think it's
time to recount i think it's time to
audit the vote
i think it's time to get answers as to
why the law was violated
at polling centers i think it's time to
figure out why you had 100 000 vote
dumps only for joe biden
i think it's time to figure out why
during the light of day
the votes came in overwhelmingly for
trump and then in the middle of the
night
votes came in for joe biden i think it's
time to figure that out
i think it's time to keep keep up this
fight i don't i do not think it is time
to roll down a roll over you're going to
see a lot of revisionist history
coming up over the pa over the next few
weeks idina menzel
who's a broadway star i guess she's been
in some movies too idina menzel
just tweeted this out it it totally
exemplifies what we're talking about
says what a relief my son just hugged me
and said mommy no more cages
tears of joy and sadness can you imagine
the tears that idina menzel is going to
cry when she finds out that joe biden
built the cages
the obama biden administration built
those cages that when we were talking
about the kids in cages and
on the on the border and because of the
illegal aliens
there were photos that went viral when
the left tried to make this argument
of little kids in cages and then they
stopped making those pictures go viral
do you know why because it turned out
those pictures were from 2014.
joe joe biden was the vice president at
the time barack obama was the president
donald trump was nowhere to be found
so all of a sudden that went away the
obama-era
cage building that then president trump
you know continued to
uh enforce the border but the policy of
separating families did it come from the
by or from the trump administration no
did it even come from the obama
administration no
or the bush administration no it came
from the clinton administration
another democratic administration
nobody nobody seems to remember that the
left does not understand history very
well or maybe they do and that's why
they want to rewrite it which is why we
should point out if
joe biden is elected this would be
history it would be historic
be not because of biden but because we
would have
the second vice president of color in
american history
which i guess i mean it's not really
that historic to be the first
vice president of color that would be
historic so it's not it isn't
particularly impressive but hey number
two that's something second band
that is true uh kamala harris would be
the second vice president
of color after charles curtis who was
the vice president from 1929 to 1933
who was the the uh vp under herbert
hoover
he was almost half indian and he was
like actually indian he was a
member of the co-nation and so that was
that was very historic kamala harris
a little bit less historic people are
going to try to jumble up their history
they're going to try to jumble up their
politics they're going to try to jumble
up the way the presidential elections
are conducted in this country and how
the winner is named
don't let them fool you it ain't over
yet
we will see everybody in court there
will be a lot more to cover
assuming president trump does not
concede which he should not do he should
not concede
and we'll just drag this out a little
bit longer and we'll and in the end
we'll find we we may get a new president
we may keep the old president
but we should look with great skepticism
on the
lame stream legacy media outlets and the
squishy corchester conservatives
who are trying to call this election
long before it's due it ain't over yet
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva and production assistant
ryan love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
you know the matte wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll give it a listen